hey guys it's Jonah here I'm in a small
village in the Kiana Greece for a
one-week wellness retreat the sun is
shining really bright the wind is
blowing strong and I'm going to put my
sunglasses on because I can barely open
my eyes so do you know what it's perfect
for a beach workout we will be doing ten
minutes of workout to work on your legs
bombs and also times only for exercises
really simple movements but really
effective
so each workout will be for 45 seconds
long with 15 seconds rest in between you
can take this work out to the beach
nearby all do it from the comfort of
your own home
get your warm-up done and let's work out
together it's going to be 4 exercises ok
45 seconds you really push yourself keep
your best if you feel that you can only
do 30 seconds then go with 30 seconds
and after that take a 30 seconds rest
all right
so 10 seconds more and the first workout
will be a reusable workout to get your
blood flowing so it's going to be squat
with forward lunge ok so step back and
lunge forward ready let's do it together
squat with forward lunge good you can
place your hand in the middle if you
want to or just keep it up good nice
there you go squat and forward again
with all your legs workout all the
squats lunges you always want to
remember keep your chest open keep your
body straight and just look forward good
few more seconds do you know what with
the sand it makes the workout a little
bit tougher because basically you're
sort of like bear it in good keep going
nice squat five more seconds
lunch lunch tighten your core and rest
get second workout will be side to side
shuffle so start in the middle shuffle
to the side touchdown
shuffle stay low and touch ok
again with the
then it will make it harder for you to
move about but really give it your best
let's go
so side to side shuffle touch stay low
touch stay low
good this is also a really good cardio
workout to get your heart rate moving to
get your legs muscle working shuffle
very nice keep going take this workout
to the beach and also do it from the
comfort of your own home and let me know
what difference you feel especially to
your leg skid 15 seconds oh my god I can
see my legs burning I can feel my heart
rate going
and one more last one and get rest it
out shake it out I can feel the wind
blowing and the Sun it's so nice to work
out in the Sun outdoor this workout will
be often at lunch to the back and I want
you to just touch down okay so the key
is to stay low and touch alright ready
let's go lunch touch down touch very
good so just really small simple
movement but by staying low you will
really work on your thighs and your bum
muscles here touch look straight ahead
if you want to or look down at one point
and just really feel the opposite legs
working as you lunge back nice lunch
good ten more seconds well it requires
more stability working on the sand rock
few more and rest it out one last man to
work out
kangaroo hops okay both work out so I
want to face towards the Sun all I want
you to do is let's see squat down hop
forward touch and hop okay to hop back
and hop whoa hop forward forward touch
back back oh my god
this is so not easy I can just feel my
feet bearing into the sand forward
forward
touch whoop back back to hop back and
hop whoa hop forward forward touch back
back oh my god
wretch one more forward and one last
time back back and take a one-minute
break okay shake it off slightly rest
take your one-minute break drink some
water
and we want to push for the second set
so we got another 10 seconds lap okay
this is the second set you know the
moves to really push yourself and give
your best and really work on your legs
bombs and engage your core as well so
let's start with the first workout squat
with forward lunge good so alternate
squat nice and deep and lunge forward
okay you want to go low enough for your
knees to touch the floor gently but do
not rest it squat nice deep squat really
fuel your butt engage and use your core
to pull yourself back up good
alternate squat again nice it's still
sunny and I just love the energy that I
get from doing my outdoor workout
I'll probably get burned a little bit
after this so last few more alternate
squat one more alternate and just rest
it out shake it out
second move side to side shuffle okay so
guilty or laugh double stab and to your
right double step so what you want to do
to focus on is to always stay low
so start low ready go doubles touch
double touch I'm sort of like fighting
against the sand touch touch good stay
low really engage your outer thighs and
your inner thighs to move from the left
to right
nice touch up touch up with her doing
good
keep pushing
feel your thighs burning for your hybrid
pumping this is one of my favorite
cardio workout which is series like this
yet
the move is so simple to follow one last
one site touch sight touch and shake it
out rest it out next we want to go back
to lunges but this time lunch bag and
just gently tap on the floor five
seconds left
catch your breath breathe in and out all
right let's go
lunge back up with your umph touch good
so just nice and easy opposite side
touch low keep a body low and touch you
can look forward if you want to or just
look down at one point okay
so as much as you can keep your body low
and lunge
okay bring your legs 90 degrees so back
leg remember to keep your back leg bends
it as well good lunch few more let me
see the clock ten more seconds keep
going whoo
nice few more one more and rest it out
my final most torturous workout
especially if you're doing it under
stand by the beach kangaroo hops so I'm
good to start here double hop forward
touch the ground double hop back all
right let's do it
squat down hop one two hop back one and
two nice forward one two nice push back
one to use your thighs use your palms to
really help with the hop push back nice
two more one
to go back nice halfway there
few more guys keep going this is final
workout
oh my god I'm feeling naked but I'm
gonna finish the workout and have the
good stretch after this
not for up back hop 1 2 aah
and just rest it out well done
right don't forget to continue to March
don't stop immediately okay I can feel
my legs burning my thighs burning and
you know what it is not easy to work out
on the beach especially with the sand in
case I challenge you to do this beach
workout and really if you want good
results do this workout three to four
times with me if you enjoy this workout
and don't forget to share it with your
friends as well okay so let me know how
you feel in the comments below and
remember to just take a deep breath in
deep breath out do your stretches and
get yourself hydrated all the best
member